and Thanksgiving it starting off
dangerously cold in many areas that'll
be a problem for at least three and a
half million people expected to be on
hand to watch the annual parade in New
York City high temperatures across the
Northeast today will be near record low
levels with just 27 degrees here in New
York City but there's also a high wind
alert which means it will feel like just
10 degrees the real field temperature in
Boston will be three degrees and in
Burlington Vermont minus six that is
cold the wind in New York could mean no
giant balloons at the parade and that
hasn't happened since 1971 the parade
route runs 46 blocks in Manhattan's
Herald Square Don de leurs at the
starting point near Central Park Don
good morning good morning and happy
Thanksgiving to you it is so cold out
here this morning that the Spider Man
float put on another set of tights
boom boom Shh alright the NYPD has until
about 9 o'clock to determine whether the
floats are going to float because of the
wind they spent most of yesterday
preparing the parade route so that the
millions of people along it will be safe
and only have to worry about having fun
and staying warm NYPD chief Terrence
Monahan is busy leading the charge to
help secure one of the biggest and
highest-profile holiday events in the
country thousands of police officers
will line the two and a half mile long
parade route sanitation trucks are
blocking intersections surveillance
cameras are posted and bomb sniffing
dogs are deployed there are other
security features you can't see we take
over the high ground so will out people
positioned up on rooftops you hold ours
up top yes I'm not gonna take exactly
ready our police got a practice run of
sorts yesterday with tens of thousands
of fans flocking to see the iconic
balloons being inflated
but history shows the weather could
provide unpredictable challenges in 1997
strong winds blew the Cata had balloon
into a metal pole two women suffered
serious head injuries and two others
were treated for minor injuries and in
2005 an M&M balloon knocked off the head
of a street lamp and left two people
with cuts and bruises people who snuck a
peek at the balloons up close say
they're ready for the brutal cold
doesn't matter how cold it is people are
gonna be happy the warmth and that
people who have being next to one
another getting to know one another
sharing sharing this parade that's all
you need it doesn't matter how cold is
people can have a great time and they'll
be safe with it here the NYPD says they
have received no credible threats now
those balloons will not come out from
under those Nets
if the sustained winds exceed 23 miles
an hour or the gusts exceed 34 but I
cross my cold fingers here but so far so
good alex is not too bad out here yet
Don I hope you have hand warmers my
friend I have a satellite truck on
wheels we're glad you have some place
records done thank you